IN ALL OF THESE -- YOU KNOW, I
GUESS FORAY, IT'S BEEN VERY --
VERY GOOD TO YOU, AND YOU KNOW,
YOU'VE GOT BEST-SELLING BOOKS.
YOU SELL OUT ON STAGE.
EVEN WITH YOUR FASHION
CRITIQUING, WHILE IT'S VERY MEAN
IN SOME WAYS.
>> IT'S NOT MEAN.
IT'S NOT MEAN.
>> REALLY?
NOT MEAN?
>> IT'S NOT MEAN.
I TELL THE TRUTH.
I'M SURE I SAY THE SAME THINGS
THAT ALL OF YOUR VIEWERS SAY TO
THEIR FRIENDS SITTING IN EX-TO
THEM ON THE COUCH.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE ONE OF THE FEW
SHOWS THAT SAYS, THAT'S AN UGLY
DRESS.
AND THAT'S OKAY.
THESE LADIES MAKE $28 MILLION A
PICTURE.
YOU REALLY THINK THAT NIKKI
MINAJ CARES, I DIDN'T LIKE HER
DRESS?
YOU KNOW, IN THAT KIND OF A
BRACKET, YOU DON'T REALLY CARE.
>> NOT REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
FEELINGS BEING HURT?
>> NOT WHEN IT'S ABOUT DRESSES.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THEM.
IT'S ABOUT CLOTHING.
>> OKAY.
WHAT ABOUT WHEN IT IS ABOUT
SOMETHING, YOU KNOW, THAT REALLY
DOES SEEM OFF LIMITS TO
THAT REALLY DOES SEEM OFF LIMITS
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
EVEN IN YOUR BOOK, YOU KIND OF
JOKE AT THE DEATH OF CASEY
ANTHONY'S BABY, PRINCESS DIANA
SURVIVING SO MANY LAND MINES AND
WHO SHE DATED.
DO YOU FEEL THERE ARE BOUNDARIES
EVER?
>> LIFE IS VERY TOUGH AND IF YOU
CAN MAKE A JOKE TO MAKE
SOMETHING EASIER AND FUNNY, DO
IT.
DONE.
DO IT.
BUT DARLING, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOUR LIFE HAS BEEN LIKE, BUT I
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
GONE THROUGH HELL AND IF YOU CAN
MAKE, WINSTON CHURCHILL SAID IF
YOU MAKE SOMEONE LAUGH, YOU GIVE
THEM A LITTLE VACATION AND MAYBE
YOU TAKE THE WORST THING IN THE
WORLD AND MAKE IT FUNNY, T A
VACATION FOR A MINUTE FROM
HORROR.
>> AND PEOPLE LOVE TO LAUGH,
CLEARLY, THAT'S WHY PEOPLE LOVE
YOU.
BUT YOU HAVE SOME SHOCK VALUE TO
ON COVER OF YOUR BOOK, YOU'RE
WEARING A FUR AND OWE PROBABLY
KNEW THERE WOULD BE ANIMAL
RIGHTS --
>> THIS WHOLE INTERVIEW HAS
BECOME A DEFENSIVE INTERVIEW.
SHUT UP.
YOU ARE WEARING FUR.
YOU'RE EATING CHICKEN.
YOU'RE EATING MEAT.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THIS
NONSENSE.
COME TO ME WITH A PAPER BELT AND
I'LL TALK TO YOU.
>> BUT YOU DID HEAR IT IN SOME
OF THOSE PRESS CONFERENCES.
YOU'RE JUST SAYING --
>> YOU KNOW, I'M GOING.
I REALLY AM GOING BECAUSE ALL
YOU HAVE DONE IS NEGATIVE.
>> NO.
>> ALL YOU HAVE DONE IS
NEGATIVE.
I MAKE PEOPLE LAUGH FOR 50
YEARS, I AM PUT ON EARTH TO MAKE
PEOPLE LAUGH, MY BOOK IS FUNNY.
I WEAR FUR THAT WAS KILLED 15
YEARS AGO.
I WORK FOR ANIMAL RIGHT, STOP IT
WITH AND YOU DO THIS AND YOU'RE
MEAN, YOU ARE NOT THE ONE TO
INTERVIEW A PERSON WHO DOES
HUMOR.
SORRY.
>> ARE WE SERIOUS?
OH, BOY.
YEAH, SHE WAS SERIOUS.
I THOUGHT SHE WAS JOKING THE
WHOLE TIME.
BUT IN THE END, WE WONDERED WAS
THIS A STUNT?
WELL, RIVERS DIDN'T RETURN TO
THE INTERVIEW, BUT OFF